renê rodoviário passado eu falei das
músicas é e tal tem uma galera que
começou a xingar os músicos mostrado no
seu pior e eu indiquei um canal a e vai
ficar aqui de novo é o canal dayse aí
faz comem de anime cover de música
normal de música normal a a isso é
normal e vamos ficar um pouquinho que
ela faz pra vocês sabem
[Música]
sorriso não estar nem senti
ei deixa o meu coração eu queria pedir
para vocês se inscreverem no canal dela
é só clicar aqui ontem altas muito legal
e ela vai colocar mais mulher ela faz
live se tocando e cantando é bem legal
da hora bacana e tadão você clique aqui
para se inscrever no canal dela não
esquece de comentar no último vídeo que
foi eu que indiquei aí galera que
assistiu o jornal tudo bom você ea bom
aqui beleza mesmo não está tão bem
porque eu acabei de chegar de cinema
está assistindo um filme chamado popéia
não é assim começa com gente morrendo o
homem chega uma espadada e morre gente
rasga pescoço e morre gente é de cavalo
moisés gente se apaixona e moisé irmão
gêmeo o gênio sentimos 19 e no final
todo mundo vira pedra
embora de cinema annie contei como é
focar na hora de você foi bom ou pouca
gente morreu muito mas foi essa espécie
que quando tem festa que tem muita gente
reclamar normal que morresse a prestar
atenção pessoa morre e liga ou mulher
ficou sabem que foi mulher lê onde
morreu dois perto da corda mulher ele
iludiu o trio é formado por mulheres
bicing primeiro carnaval que é um leve
claudia leitte hoje moro embora a
rapariga de meia hora o cara do trio
tempo para anunciar sobre a briga
a briga vai embora e vai embora
carnaval é carnaval a muita bebida né tá
eu admito que eu não sei bebê eu já
admitu lopes não sei bebê que eu sou
fraga é verdade mesmo o primeiro blog
era mais um golo não não quero nada não
só uma paixão bolinha
meu deus toma um ano dentro de mais o
mas gum sorriso e lento caro e que amava
muito e ele fosse muito para receber
curso medicina que já não suportava o
time acabar na caixa suporta uma honra
pra mim o windows só de um golo por aí
que eu vou dar outro é a menina que bebe
demais nenhum eu vou dançar com a minha
parte vou tá dançando com gripe ou
exprimir-se a dar uma nota para cada
lugar que você dança com a pessoa se
sentir aquele cheiro de alambique e se
levo levem erro do céu e cinep escutei
português e inglês japonês e ainda
deixou claro que tem e hebraico aramaico
teleco lenta em braile e ronnes o
engenheiro e achei em samba gospel leva
todo mundo novo nasceu jesus
o domingo também coloca o acordava
escutando é polêmico e vai fazer uma
coisa gostam mas não foi um abuso tão
grande quanto não sabe uma topada de
vinha caminhando pelo peixe não meu dedo
levo uma pedra tendo que leve também o
que eu dê do que nunca
pensando nas gerações futuras mulher
conversando mulher que tem nada do tal
você não se incomoda é não faz graça não
é completo
tem gente que não gosta vai ter gente
gosta por exemplo o carnaval que eu fui
lá aqui foi mas eu me teria o chanthu é
um canto muito alegando que é o tchan
ano a tim na área na direita mas que
todos ouviram de carnaval é porque todos
ouviram do canal o canal às vezes é
escuro é escuro às vezes é ruim é um e
mais uma vez pra mim às vezes a
continuar essa idéia de que toda a faixa
do povo é ruim e talvez e prefere ser o
que se essa metamorfose ambulante eu
tenho aquela velha opinião formada sobre
tudo é muito bom disse você pelo menos
não gosta de falar a respeito da área
que gostava isso aí eu quero saber de
você como é que foi o seu carnaval como
é que foi aí é o som do bloco cama com
um camarote lá no travesseiro e foi
enterrada na escolarização da janela do
seu quarto 24 banheiro ou como é que foi
o dia que você tava aí como é que foi o
carnaval conta aí e clique em gostei
porque se você clicar em gostei a escola
só dava um dia eu tinha vai entrar
dentro do templo
meu twitter tac a descrição do vídeo meu
facebook meu internet ela ficasse até
aqui falou